l'aspirine pourrait permettre de doubler
l'espérance de vie des personnes
atteintes d'un cancer gastro-intestinal
on avait déjà démontré les effets
positifs de l'aspirine pour prévenir ces
cancers mais une nouvelle étude
hollandaise constater les bienfaits de
son utilisation
après le diagnostic on sent michel nous
soit en slim a tous pris de l'aspirine
pour un mal de ventre pas mal de tête
mais pour le cancer vraiment oui il ne
cessera de nous émerveiller
cette molécule a qui est là depuis très
longtemps donc de l'aspirine du salon
commercial
en fait c'est de la has de l'acide
acétylsalicylique alors cette molécule a
en fait elle y est elle est là pour
contrôler bien des maux mais là on
découvre qu'elle a un effet
thérapeutique pour le cancer mais en
fait il s'en vend tellement céline 40
mille tonnes métriques par année c'est
la molécule la plus vendue au monde
alors qu'est ce que cette étude sur le
cancer gastro intestinaux dit au juste
ben c'est une étude importante parce que
c'est une étude qui est fait sur un
corps qui gigantesque près de 14000
patients pendant 13 ans et là on a
regardé trois cancers en particulier
donc le cancer du côlon le cancer rectal
et le cancer de l'oesophage et là on
s'est rendu compte que les gens dans ce
compte là qui en prenait après avoir eu
leur diagnostic voyait d'oublier leurs
chances de survie à 5 ans est tous en
contrôlant pour des facteurs confondants
qu'on connaît l'âge le sexe le et le
stade du cancer
alors comment est ce qu'on fait
expliquer cet essai là bas on a on a des
pièces céline parce qu'on sait que ça
éclaircit sans ça ça veut dire que les
plaquettes diminuant quantique est
normalement les cellules cancéreuses se
cachent dans les plaquettes alors là
elles sont là et elles peuvent être
détruits par notre système immunitaire
ou des bons médicaments
alors est ce qu'on peut penser imaginer
un jour un traitement préventif ou
curatif contre cette forme de cancer à
base d'aspirine
il faut être prudent céline il ya une
deuxième étude qui débute actuellement
dans le même pays où là on a donné 80
grammes par jour à une immense cohorte
avec un groupe contrôle
là on va voir quelle est son lit doses
qui sont requises il ya aussi des gens
céline qu'ils sont
un peu réfractaires aux traitements on
pense que c'est héréditaire et génétique
ils ont des problèmes d'autres ont des
problèmes gastriques donc eu des
problèmes de digestion
avec ces molécules hla donc si les gens
entendent la chronique ce soir ben c'est
pas nécessairement d'aller en prendre
mais plutôt de consulter son médecin
voir si tout ça en vaut le coup sinon
une aspirine pour la mal de tête voit
mal de ventre c'est parfait absolument
se couchait merci bonsoir